hello in this video i explain
how you can test a correlation for
significance
and that's where we start as you know
from my previous video
correlation analysis tests the linear
relationship between variables
in the first step of the correlation
analysis you calculate the correlation
coefficient
for example the pearson correlation
coefficient
or the spearman rank correlation
in general you are interested in whether
there is an association or correlation
in the whole population however
since you cannot survey the entire
population
you use your sample in order to
calculate the correlation
if there is a correlation in a sample
you still have to check
whether this correlation also exists in
the population
therefore we now come to the question of
how we can test the correlation for
significance the significance of
correlation coefficients can be tested
by using a t-test in general
it is tested whether the correlation
coefficient is significantly
different from zero in this case
the null hypothesis is that there is no
linear relationship and the alternative
hypothesis is
that there is a linear relationship we
would now like to test whether the null
hypothesis should be retained
or rejected now you're surely asking the
question
and how can i do that since the
significance of a correlation
coefficient can be tested with a t
test we must of course first calculate
the t
value the t value can be calculated with
this formula
r is the correlation coefficient we
calculated from the sample
and n is the sample size
with t and the sample size we can then
calculate the p value i will show you
how you can easily do this
online in a moment once we have
calculated the p-value
the question arises is the p-value
larger
or smaller than the previously defined
significance level
so we ask is the p-value larger
or smaller if the p-value is greater
the null hypothesis is retained if the
p-value is smaller
the null hypothesis is rejected so the
null hypothesis was there is no
correlation
accordingly if the p-value is greater
than the specified significance level
based on the existing data there is no
correlation in the population
if the p-value is smaller there is a
correlation
in the population and now as promised i
will show you
how you can easily check the correlation
coefficient for significance
online in order to do this
please visit datadeb.net and click
on the online statistics calculator
if you click on clear table you can use
your own data
please make sure the variable names are
in the first row
i will simply use the example data now
afterwards the variables that you copied
into the table above will appear here
below
we want to calculate a correlation so we
click on the
correlation tab let's say we want to
test whether there is a correlation
between
age and salary in order to do this
we simply click on the variable salary
and on the variable h now you can
calculate either the pearson or the
spearman correlation
i simply use the piece now for this
example
below we see the results here we see a
table with the correlations
and the p-value the correlation is
0.679 and the p-value is
0.015
so we can say that the p-value is lower
than the five percent
significance level based on these data
the null hypothesis is rejected
and there is a significant relationship
between
age and income if you like you can also
just have a look at the summary in words
the summary invert says that a pearson
correlation was performed
to test if there is a relationship
between salary and age
the results of the pearson correlation
indicated
that there was a significant positive
association
between salary and age if you want to
know how you can do
many more other analysis with datatab
just watch my next video i look forward
to seeing you
you